How about we take a look at a seemingly simple little puzzle.
Let's say we have a list of string pairs.
So a pair b, aabb, and a pair bba, abb, and so on, and we have some number of these pairs.
My question is, can we select from these pairs so that the 1st strings form the same strings
as the 2nd strings?
Let me show you an example to let you know what I mean.
Let's pick these pairs in the following order: The 3rd one, the 2nd one, the 4th one,
the 2nd one again, the 3rd one again, and finally the 1st one.
If we do that, and we can catenate the 1st string in the pair and can catenate the 2nd strings
in the pair, then we get this string.
If you look at these, then they are equal.
Beit they're cut in different places.
We take the 3rd one first, and we start with aabb and aa.
Then we take the 2nd one, bba here, abb here, and so on.
This problem, whether or not we can do this with a given set of strings,
is called the post correspondance problem or PCP,
after the logician Emil Post who first posed it.
Here is the really mindblowing part.
It turns out that any computer program can be stated as a PCP using just 7 pairs of strings.
Now I'd like you to tell me what this means from the given list of statements.
Does it mean that PCP is generally undecidable for 7 pairs of strings or more?
Or does it mean PCP is generally decidable for 6 pairs of strings or less?
Any SAT problem can be transformed into a PCP using 7 strings.
And finally, no PCP instance with 7 pairs of strings or more is decidable.
Check whichever statements you feel are true.